all right
[Applause]
the president's office may have conceded
a feat but many of Jay bolsonaro's
millions of supporters have not
they took to the streets of Sao Paulo in
their thousands
[Applause]
the national flag waved above the crowds
as they gathered outside the
headquarters of the military's
Southeastern command
they're calling for an intervention put
simply they want a military coup
[Music]
they despise the leftist policies of
Lula de Silva and they want him out by
any means
[Applause]
the military take over and do not new
election you know we are defended our
s how can I say Juliet
Liberty Liberty property family and our
people our family
[Music]
no commonies please we are and we
we
must to fight until we
give our Liberty
[Music]
haulage lorries began the anti-lular
protest by blocking roads across the
country it become a symbol of the
protest movement against the election
result
well these people are hoping that if
they can keep up these sort of rallies
if they can close roads and perhaps
affect the economy then the military
will intervene but so far they've said
very very little in fact it appears that
they want to maintain a completely
neutral stance
many here thought the fervor of
bolsonaro supporters would have been
dampened it hasn't been they've taken to
the streets in 70 cities across the
country
keeping the momentum going when even
bolsonaro's strongest political allies
have publicly said the game is over will
be hard for these people to achieve
it was a close election but they did
lose
Stuart Ramsey Sky News Sao Paulo